critical race theory is designed and has
effectively achieved not to explain the
history of racial injustice not to uh
reveal the truth about racial attitudes
in the united states but actually to
perpetuate a sense of division to to to
instill this idea that we can be
separated into oppressor and oppressed
classes and to revive some of the
ugliest tropes and ideas uh from the
kind of racist uh
race science of the 1920s
things like race essentialism like
collective guilt
like
neo-segregation and then re-implant them
in our institutions
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
senior fellow at the manhattan institute
and one of america's most prominent
critics of critical race theory
christopher roofer welcome to
trigonometry it's good to be with you
it's great to have you on listen before
we dive into all this fascinating stuff
just tell everybody here particularly
here in the uk we have an international
audience but there may be many people
who are not familiar with you first of
all who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that brings you to be here talking
to us
yeah you know i am uh
born and raised in california on the
west coast of the united states and uh
after i graduated from university i
worked for more than 10 years as a
documentary filmmaker
i directed four films for pbs which is
our equivalent of the bbc roughly uh i
sold the film to netflix a number of
years ago and then in the last few years
i've gotten uh kind of transitioned from
pure documentary filmmaking to getting
involved in more social and political
issues and then shifted my own kind of
field of of my own domain my own field
of expertise from
kind of the filmmaking process to a
journalism writing advocacy process and
i found myself
almost exactly a year ago a little bit
more than a year ago now
kind of accidentally becoming one of the
primary critics of critical race theory
as you explained and it really happened
to me very briefly
because i started reporting on these
issues reporting on training programs
reporting on critical race theory in
schools reporting on critical race
theory in corporations and
became the kind of go-to source for
whistleblowers all over the united
states that we're seeing these ugly and
divisive tenets of critical race theory
uh starting to make headway and take
over their institutions
uh christopher the one thing that i
really take away from that is you've had
a life which theoretically would make
you super woke right you grew up in
california you make documentaries uh you
know you're married to a thai american
woman you've got mixed-race kids like
how did you how did this become a thing
for you yeah i guess that's right yeah i
mean like you would you would add up all
those things and you would say somehow
that probably equals awoke you know i
was um
to the left as a younger person and my
growing up in high school for the first
bit of college um but
you know the ideas of the left started
for me to break down as i saw more of
the world as a documentary filmmaker i
had a chance to travel to
i think 70 plus countries around the
world i've seen a lot i've seen the
highs the lows the awful the beautiful
everything in between and as i actually
looked at the world in a very up close
and personal way all the different
systems of government all the different
cultures um i i quickly realized well
slowly realized actually um that these
ideas that i grew up with these ideas
that i had been stewing in these ideas
that i had been taught at in in a
university setting just didn't hold up
to reality and it took me a while to
then i guess move to the right it took
me a number of years um but once i
started actually uh kind of
not just having the caricature of
conservative thought or conservative
politics but actually started doing the
reading doing the homework understanding
a bit
more about the kind of conservative
philosophy the conservative body of work
over the last you know 100 years or so
it started to me
to match my experience with reality
more closely not perfectly of course
nothing is perfect uh but but but that
was kind of my own
journey my own transition and i think as
things have gone into kind of hyper
drive wokeness in the last four or five
years uh that that transition seemed to
be more prescient and more accurate uh
than ever
and
what is crystal critical race theory and
why it's the second part to that
question is why is it so dangerous to
our society
yeah so you know critical race here i'll
try to give you a kind of succinct
summaries critical race theory is an
academic discipline uh it's a
neo-marxist philosophy derived from
critical theory uh which really took
hold in the united states around 1965
and it holds something very simple it
says that the united states is a
fundamentally racist country
founded on white supremacy patriarchy
and capitalist exploitation and that
those forces are still at the root of
our society today and even though it may
seem that we've made progress the
critical race argue that in many ways we
haven't made any progress the country is
just as racist exploitative and
patriarchal today as it was a hundred
years ago or 200 years ago those forces
have merely become more subtle more
sophisticated and more insidious the
conclusion then that the critical race
theorists arrive at is that all of our
systems must be deconstructed dismantled
and demolished in order for a better and
utopian society to emerge this includes
capitalism they're explicitly
anti-capitalist
this includes
kind of gender relations and family
structure that they want to kind of
dismantle and deconstruct and i think it
also crucially uh includes our system of
constitutional government where they are
deeply skeptical of the first amendment
right to free speech the 14th amendment
right to equal protection
and and so on and so forth um so
when you kind of arrive at it in its
totality uh and the early work is
explicit even though they've tried to
kind of cover their tracks lately
it is not a program of reform it's not
an extension of a civil rights movement
it's actually a program of liberation or
revolution uh that was outlined in the
early years in the 1960s as critical
theory uh taking on a racial component
into 1990s and now seemingly has spread
throughout our institutions
and you said it spread right the way
through our institutions it seems to
have come to prominence in the last year
or so why is that do you think it's
related to what's been happening in
america or do you think it exploded into
the public consciousness because of
lockdowns because of blm because of
covid
i think a bit of both i mean certainly
in my reporting what i've seen is that
some of the earliest school districts to
adopt the principles of critical race
theory and their teacher training
programs or their curricula we're doing
so around 2010. i know portland public
schools was an early adopter that's
portland oregon kind of the the home of
antifa one of the wokest place on earth
um
they were adopting it around 2010 in in
a kind of tentative kind of light way
but certainly what you've seen is that
school districts not just in portland or
berkeley or new york or boston but
actually
kind of middle america school districts
suburban school districts
all started to adopt it around the same
time following the death of george floyd
which of course followed the coveted
lockdowns and then was kind of uh
succeeded by these large-scale protests
and then large-scale riots
and uh you see the documentation um from
these school districts and it's like a
immediate domino effect it's actually a
pretty profound process of of of of of
spread of contagion where all of these
school districts around the country are
adopting the same kind of board
resolutions the same kind of training
programs the same kind of curriculum
modules things that have been in
development for years and decades
all of a sudden in the environment of
covet lockdown in the environment of
remote school in the environment of
ongoing racial unrest they suddenly
became adopted almost everywhere
simultaneously and
this i think is um significant not only
in itself but it's also significant
because what we've seen
since i started really exposing it
reporting on it others have been working
on this issue as well we've seen a
tremendous backlash and a tremendous
resistance to this um you know not only
race conscious but really racially
divisive uh program in schools uh
christopher before we get into into the
the real kind of implementation of some
of this stuff which is very important i
know you've done a lot of work on it uh
let's explore just the theory itself and
you know you laid out i think uh an
accurate description of what i
understand to be critical race theory
and the beginning part of it isn't it
isn't it accurate to say that the united
states was founded
it was at its foundation at least let's
say a society that did involve elements
certainly of racism i don't know about
white supremacy but probably white
supremacy capitalist exploitation
patriarchy aren't those things all quite
accurate to point out
yeah well i i think that there is a a
subtle but very important distinction i
mean you can certainly say that i mean
undoubtedly anyone anyone would agree
that that when the united states was
founded uh slavery was a widespread
practice racial discrimination injustice
uh exploitation of course but they're
not making that argument that these are
historical realities that we should
grapple with that we should seek to
understand and if they have any
kind of residual effects today we should
seek to rectify
that's an argument that i've made that's
an argument that i believe to be true
what they're saying is that the the
united states is fundamentally in its
foundation and irredeemably
racist patriarchal and exploitative and
this is then the premise for the
conclusion not a program of reform but a
program that it has to be abolished so
you have things like abolitionist
teaching abolish prisons abolish you
know the constitution abolish the united
states as a kind of historical entity
itself in some cases and and it lays the
foundation for not a a kind of
responsible look at history trying to
understand the bad and the good trying
to sort it out they say even the
declaration even the civil war even the
civil rights act are remnants of white
supremacy or remnants of domination are
mechanisms for racial control and i
think that those are that that's in in
some ways a subtle distinction but i
think it's very important because the
story that i think is accurate and how i
think that that history should be taught
in schools for example
is that you should take an honest and
hard look at the history of racism
slavery segregation and justice et
cetera
but you should also place those
historical injustices within the context
of the country's highest ideals
first kind of declared in the
declaration uh codified in the
constitution
fought over and and and and consecrated
in blood in the civil war
and then put into kind of specific legal
practice in the civil rights act that's
always moving towards the principles of
freedom and equality that were really
the founding essence of our society um
you know not
racial injustice exploitation we don't
live currently in a slaveocracy as some
critical race theorists have argued um
the the language is uh is very important
and it's very important to make those
distinctions because now what we've seen
is precisely what you're suggesting
they're they're now conflating all of
these things together to try to conceal
the true nature of their philosophy
and christopher the way you describe it
abolishing prisons abolishing the united
states the the civil rights act is is a
remnant of whites that all of that
sounds insane right to a normal person
to a normal reasonable person i hope
that's still true i
i really hope so i have no doubt that
it's true i think the vast majority of
the public completely wouldn't buy into
that so if that is the case and let's
just say for the sake of argument say
that it is insane and it's crazy
how has it happened that in a very short
period of time
this ideology has not only become
popularized in in a small minority of
people who talk about it but is actually
now bleeding into our institutions how
has that happened
well i think
there's a there's a there's a key
key mechanism that you have to
understand to explain that um this is
still a very much a kind of numerical
minority position uh very few people
subscribe to critical race theory uh
very few people in the general public
support critical race theory uh the
latest polling data shows that by a 19
percent margin americans who have an
opinion about this
oppose it
and this includes
latinos and asians that oppose critical
race theory in schools by a two to one
margin um so it is
deeply unpopular it is it is a
very kind of small
numerical minority position
but the people who are true believers
the people who are the most fierce
advocates for this philosophy
are in those bureaucratic positions
predominantly in public institutions so
government jobs
where they can actually impose this
without the consent of voters without
the consent of parents without the
consent of the public uh they can
implement it in many cases uh
unilaterally through a bureaucratic
process so you have all of these uh kind
of woke bureaucrats in public schools in
municipal governments in state
governments in the federal bureaucracy
everywhere as i've documented in my
investigative reporting
that are
really taking these ideas and very
astutely very shrewdly
they've then covered them in euphemism
so instead of the revolutionary theory
to abolish capitalism they're saying
equity inclusion diversity uh very nice
very soft sounding words that are
in themselves kind of unopposable
but then underneath if you actually look
at the documentation
even in fortune 100 companies of all
places
they're they're laundering in these more
uh kind of revolutionary principles
these these these more radical ideas um
and uh and that's what we're seeing and
i think that a lot of it is uh
this this this confluence of
of of public bureaucracies of an
apathetic citizenry and then these
ideologies that have leaked out of the
university system well maybe not leaked
out actually been been exported from
very deliberately from university
systems to k-12 education to
you know federal state and local
bureaucracies
but wouldn't you say christopher as well
that
in some ways the fact that this has
come to prominence shows that america
there's still a problem with race
there's still anger that surrounds it
and what we see with critical race
theory is people trying to explain the
injustices that they still see in
america
yeah i i would take a different and
perhaps more cynical view i actually
think that if you look at the polling
data from uh from gallup and others for
example um
the kind of racial attitudes the idea of
kind of uh
is there kind of racial harmony is there
racial integration is there uh
cooperation and trust between racial
groups in the united states was actually
very high as as recently as 10 years ago
it was roughly 70 percent of white
americans uh slightly less somewhere in
the high 60 percent of of african
americans uh believed that race
relations in the united states were good
starting in about 2013 2014 and
continuing today to to
today those numbers have plummeted
they've been reduced by roughly half uh
so you have a very paradoxical situation
where you have a kind of progression of
a
legal regime of equality over time that
somehow peaks in the kind of 2000s and
then mysteriously uh just absolutely
plummets among all racial groups and i
would say my hypothesis again it's very
hard to kind of
prove this in a social science method
but
i i think that uh my hypothesis is that
critical race theory is designed and has
effectively achieved not to explain the
history of racial injustice not to
reveal the truth about racial attitudes
in the united states but actually to
perpetuate a sense of division
to to to instill this idea that we can
be separated into oppressor and
oppressed classes and to revive some of
the ugliest tropes and ideas
from the kind of racist uh
race science of the 1920s uh things like
race essentialism like collective guilt
like
neo-segregation and then re-implant them
in our institutions of course under
different pretexts with different stated
goals but this is what we see we see for
example in crass classrooms where
students are being told that they are
either a member of the oppressor or the
oppressed class based on their skin
color they're being told that they are
guilty and responsible for historical
crimes committed by people who look like
them in the past and they're also in the
process of teacher training for example
in employee training programs
adults are being separated into separate
facilities separate programs based on
race and i think that this is
very ugly it's it's it's very much
counterproductive and if the polling
data is accurately reflects the kind of
uh the
the the the spread or the hold of this
ideology uh it is actually tearing
people apart rather than bringing them
together
and christopher what would you say those
people who would give you the first
amendment art argument which is look
we have freedom of speech in this
country you know this is a theory just
like marxism just like libertarianism
it should be free to be taught like any
other theory in our public schools in
our colleges in our universities
yeah well i i you know i'm i'm obviously
or maybe not obviously i should make it
clear you know i'm a supporter of the
first amendment i think it's essential
there's a reason why they put it uh
first of all the amendments uh but i i
think that you you have to understand
that this isn't a freedom of speech
issue
of course if you're a critical race
theorist i support your right a hundred
percent to go on the street corner to
publish in the newspaper to write a book
about critical race theory uh to to to
preach it as radically as you want as
often as you want
but we're talking about a context of
publicly funded and publicly governed
institutions like for example k-12
schools k-12 schools are government
entities that are that are beholden that
are responsible and accountable to
taxpayers uh and the first amendment uh
in the case law and its own kind of
intention was designed to protect
individuals from the government not to
protect the government from the
individuals or government from the
voters so
as these institutions function they
include and exclude certain ideas we
don't have uh we're not teaching
kindergartners eugenics we're not
teaching them phrenology we're not
teaching them flat earthism you can
preach all of those things from the
street corner if you want as a first
amendment right but you're not entitled
to include them in the official state
curriculum
that is a political decision it's a
political process it's determined by
state legislatures it's determined by uh
local board school boards uh and boards
of education uh so
they get to decide what is in the
curriculum what is out of the curriculum
uh teachers this is kind of first
amendment uh kind of jurisprudence case
law for for many years
they don't have an unlimited first
amendment right in the classroom it's
restricted because they're public
employees
so this idea that somehow uh you know uh
one group gets the exclusive and and
kind of right to use taxpayer dollars to
promote their private ideology within
public institutions uh doesn't stand up
to scrutiny and christopher tell us a
little bit about some of the work that
you've been doing because i said at the
top of your introduction that you are
one of the most prominent critics of
this but actually i think it's more
accurate to say that you're one of the
people who's been doing the most to
actively oppose uh all of this in the
institution so you've had some success
in that area tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so i you know it really all started
for me with uh the the reporting i think
that um it's one thing to criticize a
theory uh where you can say uh hey this
is a this is this is critical race
theory this is what it what it holds
this is why it's wrong uh you engage in
a very abstract argument and uh you can
win or lose sometimes it's very unclear
who wins or who loses in those kind of
debates uh whereas my approach and my
strategy and then my kind of skill set
was to actually expose the most
egregious and sometimes salacious
examples from public schools so just
very quickly you have like teaching
third graders in cupertino california
to deconstruct their racial and sexual
identities and then rank themselves
according to a hierarchy of power and
privilege uh so dividing you know
eight-year-olds into oppressor and
oppressed um uh you have the kind of
system in in in buffalo new york
teaching uh k-12 students that quote all
white people perpetuate systemic racism
uh that all white wealth derives from
slavery and that white people are quote
unfairly rich
and then sharing uh video a video
dramatization of dead black children
this is to kindergartners to four and
five-year-olds speaking to them beyond
the grave warning them that quote uh
racist police could murder them at any
minute um like
instilling this kind of race-based
terror in in in small children
or even a public high school in new york
city that sent an email to white
directed to white parents
that said that they need to become quote
uh white traders to betray the white
race and then to advocate for quote
white abolition so abolishing uh the
white race which is an idea from
critical race theory and critical
whiteness studies um those are just
three of the examples and and the idea
was to basically cut through the gas
light and cut through the line cut
through the obfuscation cut through the
euphemisms and show people you know
these stories did about 250 million
direct media impressions in the united
states they really brought this issue to
the forefront uh you see the kind of fox
news numbers mentions of critical race
theory uh following my kind of work and
exposes uh just absolutely skyrockets
and then now what you've seen is a fight
on three fronts there are legal cases
some of which i've been involved in
helping
that are trying to get to the supreme
court to show that these practices are
not only morally wrong but actually
illegal and unconstitutional there is a
legislative effort we've now passed
state legislative bills or state board
of education
uh resolutions in nine states covering
75 million americans a banning critical
race theory indoctrination in public
k-12 schools that's a huge victory and
then we also see this grassroots revolt
from parents all over the country you've
probably seen many clips on twitter
parents going berserk at school board
meetings saying i don't want you to
teach my kid that he's an oppressor i
don't want you to teach my kid that she
is a member of the oppressed get this
out of the classroom when you talk about
critical race theory which is pretty
much going to be teaching kids how to
hate each other
how to dislike each other that's pretty
much what it is that's pretty much all
on camera it's pretty much what it's
going to all come down to you're going
to deliberately teach kids this white
kid right here got it better than you
because he white you're gonna personally
tell a white kid oh the black people are
all down and suppressed how do i have
two medical debris if i'm sitting here
oppressed how do i get first of all this
is uh white parents black parents asian
parents latino parents native american
parents parents from across the
political spectrum it's a broad-based
movement uh it's grassroots it's
decentralized um and it is totally uh
organic in its presentation and nature
and they are really holding school
boards accountable and i live in outside
of seattle washington one of the bluest
kind of areas in the country if not the
world
and even to my surprise something that i
wasn't directly involved in i saw in the
paper that my local school board had
voted 5-0 to ban critical race their
indoctrination in our local schools so
uh this is something that is uh is
happening at it honestly it'd be very
frank to a degree that astonished me i
mean i when i started this i could not
imagine that it would snowball so
quickly uh and and and rack up such
incredible results uh uh in at this kind
of time frame well i would argue that
given some of the i mean what you've
described there is
i mean it's atrocious it is it is
horrendous uh what you're talking about
there uh so it kind of makes sense that
a lot of people would thankfully be a
poster but there's a question i have for
you because you talked about you
yourself moving from being on the left
to being more right-leaning you've
talked about uh talking about these
things on fox news etc neither francis
or i are right wing or on the right and
uh we we both it depends who you ask
some people would probably say you are
some people yeah yeah a lot of people on
the left would say we're on the right
yeah but but the thing is they don't
know what they're talking about so i
guess the interesting question for me
here would be francis and i would
obviously uh completely against what
you're describing that four year olds
and five year olds being taught about
the racial guilt i mean it's just
atrocious but
what is why is it a right-wing thing to
oppose this i don't understand i mean
there are plenty of reasonable sensible
intelligent people on the left
is what's what's a good left-wing
argument against this stuff
well i i mean
there's a well i think you have to
distinguish between the kind of hardcore
racialist left and then the kind of
classical liberal or center-left
liberals and in fact a lot of
center-left liberals oppose this and
among independents for example people
who kind of don't go hard one way or
another 72 percent of american
independent voters oppose this ideology
in schools and i hear from people who
are on the center left all the time in
places like san francisco and places
like new york city where they say hey
i'm a good democrat i've been a lifelong
kind of uh left leaner but this is
insane we have to get this stuff out of
our schools we have to get this stuff
out of new york city private schools uh
for example or or or or los angeles
public schools but those voices aren't
amplified and those voices unfortunately
are not attached to any kind of
political power because the people who
run the kind of party machinery the
intellectual machinery of the left in
the united states currently are very
much on that hard racialist left uh
flank and they really could care less
and they actually viciously uh kind of
undermine the people on the center left
so the
the it's really not a question of well a
lot of center left left people oppose it
but the only reason we're seeing results
in more conservative school boards more
conservative districts more conservative
states is because those voters that make
up a
strong majority it's you know 90
plus of conservative voters oppose this
uh they have recourse through the
political system because they can lobby
their state legislatures we could which
get to pass bills they can lobby their
local school boards which are more
responsive uh but i think we're seeing
that even now shifting where certainly
the right has basically shored up this
side and said nope we're not going to do
this but we're seeing now even swing
districts even uh
school districts
in kind of
purple areas so halfway between democrat
and republican they're starting to flip
uh center-left voters are coming out
strong latino voters are coming out
strong asian voters are coming out
strong to oppose this ideology i think
we're seeing a shifting of the
battlefield the shifting of the the
landscape of power and i think that my
well i i hope rather my my hope is that
uh we can continue to build this
coalition that spans from the the right
to the center left uh that encompasses
all uh different racial and ethnic
backgrounds to really come with a united
front to say this is not necessarily
just a left-right issue of course it is
uh but this is an issue of of of of
fundamental principles about what it
means uh to live in a constitutional
republic in the united states of america
in 2021
we have the vast majority that opposes
this we're not going to let a a a very
small group of of of committed
ideologues who've embedded themselves in
the bureaucracy to override the
democratic will of american voters we're
actually going to stop this we're going
to put our foot down
together
hey francis do you want to learn another
language no mate i'm english if
foreigners can't understand me i just
shout at them think about it you could
learn how to say penalties in italian
leave it but if you do want to learn
another language because maybe you want
to have new experiences live in another
country or maybe you just want to open
your mind my mind's open enough if i
open it up any further my brain's going
to hurt this is true but babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
they design their courses with practical
real world conversations in mind
sentences you will use in normal
everyday life sentences like oi pedro
dos services paul favor thank you
francis and bible's courses have been
proven to be scientific
and bible's courses have been proven to
be scientifically effective across
multiple studies their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go it's available as an
app or online and your progress will be
synced across all devices you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
they've also got their own podcast so
you can brush up on your french and
spanish on the go start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and before you know it
espanol absolutamente perfecto now i
mean gary right now babel is offering
our listeners six months free with a
purchase of a six month subscription
with our promo code which is of course
trigger go to uk dot babble dot com
slash play and use promo code trigger
for an extra six months free that's uk
dot b a b b e l dot c o m forward slash
play promo code
trigger and christopher uh disclosure
i'm a former teacher so everyone and i
mention it in every episode um teaching
is
it's a phenomenally difficult job
you've got to look after the kids
pastorally you've got to teach them
you've got to make sure that they all
make progress you know there's going to
be ones who are more adept there's going
to be ones who fall behind
i don't understand how they have the
time to teach all this stuff and be able
to make sure that kids get a rounded
education how can they do that well
you know it there really is kind of a
really interesting thing that's
happening and i think it would maybe
illuminate the answer to your question
is that there are two kinds of schools
that i've seen in my reporting that are
pushing the critical race theory there
are the very elite affluent big city
schools including private schools so the
kind of places where it's you know fifty
thousand dollars a year maybe like
thirty thousand pounds i don't know the
exchange rate a year uh to attend these
schools i mean these are you know the
most affluent elite places in the
country they've adopted it because they
in my my reading they believe that being
fluent in the language of wokeness uh is
essential for advancing in the ivy
league institutions is essential for
advancing in elite workplaces like
consulting firms and and and government
and politics and journalism so they're
preparing their kids not to be uh kind
of uh you know throwing molotov
cocktails uh into a police car although
that does sometimes happen even among
this set but they're preparing them for
this kind of meritocratic system that
has been really uh that wokeness has
grafted itself onto but you also see it
and i think and like whatever who cares
i really don't care personally what they
do and they leave private schools i
think they shouldn't do it but it's
really up to them
um
those kids are going to be fine
but where it really concerns me and
frankly enrages me is in the big city uh
poor school districts uh with high rates
of educational failure so for example
like like buffalo which i talked about
also
philadelphia pennsylvania uh these are
big urban school districts high number
of black students uh in those two
courses they're teaching a very uh
aggressive uh kind of critical race
theory based curriculum in the case of
buffalo from from pre-k through grade 12
they've overhauled their curriculum
and
the tragedy and the thing that i think
should infuriate
voters and parents and families
is that this is a these are school
districts where in some schools uh their
literacy rates are less than 20 percent
sometimes less than 10 percent so kids
who are uh unable to reach basic
proficiency in reading and writing you
have sometimes 80 percent of students
that are functionally illiterate by the
time they graduate from uh their kind of
primary school or middle school uh
education so you have uh you know an
educational crisis you have kids in
fifth sixth grade that are illiterate
that have been in school for you know 6
000 hours of classroom time that can't
read can't write at a basic level and
yet they're pumping them full of
ideology and the cynical read on this
which i think unfortunately has a lot of
truth is that this is used as a
diversion tactic uh to
shift the focus away from the failures
of these of these institutions the
failures of teachers unions the failures
of the school districts the failures of
principals and classroom teachers in
these districts
and then shift the blame onto the
abstract forces
that are the kind of
is almost a kind of a
a safety valve mechanism a scapegoating
mechanism well it's not that our schools
are crumbling and dysfunctional and
failing to teach you how to read it's
actually the fault of
of of of white supremacy the fault of
anthropocentrism the fault of you know
whatever kind of uh kind of kind of evil
villain of the day is
and and i think that to me is just uh is
that unconscionable and um
and uh those stories for me were the
really the most tragic the most
difficult uh the most heartbreaking to
report i can i can imagine so and what
is the effect of this type of teaching
on the kids do they respond to it i mean
look because like i said i talk there's
a lot of time where i taught kids stuff
and they went out and they you you could
have asked them a question for a million
dollars and they wouldn't have been able
to answer it that's just more your
teaching style yeah it's good about you
[Music]
that's why he's no longer a teacher mate
yeah right right um yeah now you have a
kind of a a voluntary audience so this
is better so you don't have the captive
audience but
it's in some ways it's too early to tell
um long term what happens but i can
share with you um some uh anecdotes that
could suggest maybe where it's going i i
spoke recently to a father actually who
kind of a clip who went viral on youtube
i met him in arizona when i was giving a
speech
a black father um actually met a number
of interracial couples black white
couples
and um and he said hey you know this
year after black history month where
they were doing the black lives matter
curriculum they're doing the critical
race theory style curriculum
my kids who are you know half half black
half white uh i kind of present as black
i guess is the way they would say it um
they came home and even my 10 year old
was terrified uh he couldn't eat he
couldn't sleep he would come back into
the bed with with his mother and me
you know which he hadn't done in years
and i finally talked to him and asked
him what happened he's like i'm
terrified i'm scared i feel like i'm
going to be hunted down by society i
feel like police can murder me at any
moment i feel like i should hate uh you
know
uh you know
people who look like mom um and the
father was just kind of horrified he's
like what are they teaching in black
history and then started going to the
school board to advocate and he said you
know they're trying to fill my kids with
fear with my kids with a sense that they
can't accomplish anything in life a
sense that they'll be forever oppressed
uh but this gentleman said look i grew
up in in in in the hood in in watts or
compton california um i know what it's
like to struggle we live in a good
neighborhood now we've moved up i want
to fill my kids with a sense of
possibility a sense of inspiration a
sense of potential
and this is actually in the name of
doing good they're actually doing harm
to my kids
another couple uh said that this
curriculum an interracial couple
uh uh said that that this was ripping
their own family apart that it was it
was having their kids coming home saying
you know should we hate grand our
grandfather who's a a white person uh
should you know is he an oppressor is he
a bad person is he is he one of the you
know people that wants to you know uh
you know harm us or hurt us
and and and really just kind of
could uh had their parents not
intervened and explained them the truth
uh ripped these families apart uh so i i
think that uh
on that side i've seen damage done and
then also you know i reported on a story
in portland oregon a long kind of
reported feature
where i think that there's a direct line
from the kind of ideology that's being
promoted in schools to the rioting
disruption antifa
uh attacks against uh property and and
people um and you had for example in
portland this was documented by andy noe
who's a great uh reporter on this
uh that actually i think four or three
or four uh portland public school
teachers people in elementary schools
and middle schools and high schools were
arrested for
crimes including felony crimes of
rioting including violent crimes during
these political protests so um
this is again it's early this stuff in
many places is still very early but the
early signs are very bad they should be
a kind of red
spinning warning light
for any administrator or teacher that's
considering this kind of curriculum
and the stuff you're talking about there
christopher i mean i i have to say i
find it terrifying because
i i this is really the question i want
to ask you is are you optimistic and are
you positive because when i think and i
play the movie forward if you teach a
generation of young people
uh this racial animus that maps so
neatly onto our
hard-wired tribal prejudices that exist
within all human beings i i wonder
whether there is a positive outcome here
do you know what i mean it sounds really
scary
yeah it it it does it it sounds very
scary it is it is very scary in some
regards but ultimately i am optimistic
and i'm optimistic because what we've
seen
uh uh
in the
us and hopefully elsewhere i i don't
really know uh but uh at least since
kind of february march of this year the
last three months i mean we've seen an
incredible awakening of parents of
voters of school board members of
politicians of state legislatures uh
people are taking this issue very
seriously and what i would like to see
i think what is a a hopeful uh hopeful
vision but also a very realistic vision
uh something that is that is uh
kind of already happening if you will is
that we're we'll see in our federal
system our kind of federalist system of
government we'll see states pursuing
very different courses of action uh the
curriculum in california and oregon and
washington state very liberal states
will look very different from uh texas
oklahoma and florida which are more
conservative states and they will embark
on this experiment
do you want woke politics as the
founding ideology of your education
system or do you not and over time what
results do those yield and i think that
eventually people will see that this is
not the way that this doesn't lead to
better outcomes and and i think
crucially and one thing that i find it
important to say is that
um
in the us
despite how the kind of msnbc or the new
york times would like to present it
this is not a really white black issue
as i already said uh latinos and asians
oppose this style of curriculum by two
to one margins in the polling data
african americans support it but by just
a i believe a five-point margin very
narrowly kind of almost 50 50.
uh i think that will shift over time uh
in our favor as people understand what
this is really about
um it's really a question
of of what is going to create better
outcomes for kids and
i think most americans now understand it
won't create better outcomes for kids
but i think if you take a step back and
you look at critical race theory you
know
critical race theory if we if we
implemented the policy the radical and
extreme policies that critical race
theory has formulated uh my argument and
i wrote a policy paper about this for
heritage foundation which is a think
tank here in the united states uh uh my
argument is that it would create
negative outcomes
you know the critical race theorists
oppose merit-based education
they oppose kind of in some cases even
even assigning grades which are a racist
a racist practice so they oppose kind of
merit-based achievement in education
they oppose a nuclear family structure
in many of their of many of their papers
they think that the nuclear family
structure which social science has shown
definitively kind of left and right to
be the essential precondition for people
who grow up
in rough circumstances for them to
move up the income ladder they also
oppose entry-level work which they say
is again capitalist exploitation so when
you take away those three building
blocks and when you teach kids that
those things are not only not important
but actually evil and wrong and
oppressive you take away merit-based
academic achievement you take away a
strong family structure and strong a
household and then you take away the
desire to get into the labor force to
start working your way up the income
ladder uh you're going to create a a
kind of more desperate uh and and more
dire situation especially for people in
low-income groups especially for
racial minorities so i think critical
race theory is a recipe for disaster
all that it does is help
bolster the social status of
multi-racial elites in academia in
government and policy making but if it
were implemented would be devastating
for the kids uh who need who are who
desperately need uh the most help who
desperately need a society that will
lift them up
it's a very very very good point i'm
listening to you and i'm thinking where
are the teachers in this
are they all blindly following it are
they being dictated to by the unions
what's happening
well i'll tell you in my reporting i've
talked to a lot of teachers and and and
i'm trying to remember yes every single
one of them i did maybe 13 14 reports on
schools um
every single one of them requested
complete anonymity
because they're afraid that if their
name and their voice or their face is
attached
to opposition uh to critical race theory
in schools they'll get fired they'll get
ostracized they'll get bullied uh
protesters will show up at their house
and intimidate them
their colleagues will scream at them
which has happened in a number of cases
that i've reported on
and so they're scared even teachers who
deeply oppose it in a principled way are
scared to speak out and then on the top
what we've seen is that the largest
teachers union in the united states the
nea national educate education
association or educators association
which represents 3 million teachers in
all 14 000 school districts
just this summer uh at their annual
conference at their annual congress
voted in committee as an institution to
support implementing critical race
theory in all 14 000 school districts in
all 50 states they've gone on the record
by name critical race theory saying we
support this we want to put this
everywhere and they've also approved
funding to attack people like me to
attack journalists and writers and
intellectuals who are opposing critical
race theory they're going to put their
part of their 375 million dollar annual
budget into attacking us into
intimidating us into coming after us uh
so these institutions which i don't
think reflect the majority of their
members have been captured by this
ideology it's a top-down revolution it's
a revolution from above it's an elite
driven revolution and they want to
impose it
from their position of power and
privilege ironically
on to the rank and file people of all
different social classes all different
racial backgrounds who by large
majorities oppose it christopher but
other than their revolutionary mindset
which you've detailed
surely they must have some good
arguments aren't they uh what what what
is the strongest argument in favor of
introducing the stuff in school that
people make
this is a good question i mean it
depends right i mean
the
the premise is right i would say that
the premise is a strong premise the
premises the united states has a history
of of racial injustice and we should
make sure to uh to to to look at look at
history through the lens of racial
injustice to illuminate areas where the
united states has fallen short of its of
its ideals of freedom and equality i
think
virtually everyone in the country if you
put it to them that way if you
implemented it in those terms would it
would support it
but the problem is is that uh
that is really a kind of a a kind of
mott and bailey a kind of a kind of
presentation argument uh that really
masks the real content of it um because
you know you can say that i would agree
with it i think both of you would agree
with it um most parents would agree with
it including conservative parents um
yeah we should really take a look at
this this history we should really teach
kids the deepest injustices in our past
but also the progress that we've made
towards realizing those ideals
that i think could get almost universal
support but the critical ratios are
deploying that argument uh
disingenuously but then implementing
things like like segregating employees
like telling children that they're
inherently oppressive like telling you
know small uh young people that they are
have a kind of blood guilt or ancestral
guilt or collective guilt based on skin
color uh those things
aren't connected those things those
conclusions those practices don't follow
from the premise so i think that what we
could do theoretically uh although i'm
not optimistic about this is we can say
hey look we agree on the premise uh we
agree on the premise that we should take
a look at these issues
we disagree with your conclusions but
let's try to come up with a better
curriculum a better practice from that
common premise and to the extent that
it's possible you're never going to
convince the people on the fringes to
the extent that it's possible get a
large majority of of citizens whether
it's locally or or statewide or
nationally to agree on a new approach to
address these issues
in a way that is kind of broadly uh
popular and reflects uh it reflects the
truth frankly uh that reflects an
accurate reading of history
and christopher what would you say to
those people who go look right this is
very interesting as an episode but i
live in sweden you know the uk whatever
and it's not going to affect me
i don't know man i think uh i i don't
know and i i i would defer to you guys
uh to to to you too in the uk but um
from what i've seen from what i've been
reading uh these are um you know i'll
tell you what this is how this is how
i'll put it
america has has demonstrated one immense
capacity and one immense talent uh we
take things uh from all over the world
we we package them into commodities and
then we export them to every country on
the planet i mean you can go to a kind
of remote tibetan village that has just
achieved electricity and watch michael
jackson dance videos with buddhist monks
i mean that's i've actually done that i
mean it it really is extraordinary the
the reach of america's cultural
commodities so if it hasn't successfully
been exported to you
in the uk into sweden into other
countries uh it will be it's coming and
i think even uh the president of france
i saw that he said if france is being uh
affected negatively by all of these
american ideas which i thought was
was amazing a kind of a dodge uh francis
had its share of bad ideas uh but uh but
i i think that it's certainly coming uh
even in relatively
societies
like the scandinavian societies i don't
think they'll be immune to this this
politics once it takes hold once it gets
a foothold
in institutions it's very hard to
dislodge it's very hard to disrupt and
seems to spread uh quite easily
christopher we're gonna have to wrap up
in a few minutes but before we do i
wanted to talk about the role of the
media in all of this because uh you and
i interacted recently on twitter over
the long thread i wrote about the
falling trust in public institutions
particularly the media uh what do you
think has been the role of the media in
advancing this theory or opposing it or
you know the role of different media
outlets on different sides in in having
this debate and facilitating the
conversation
oh i mean i mean i think the media is
uh the media is is is the um if academia
is the
the flame you know if academia is the
origin the flame
the media is the accelerant you know
it's like the the lighter fluid that's
being squirted over the top of the flame
uh the the media has has done uh you
know
an an incredibly bad job promoting this
stuff and you see the numbers from the
social scientist zach goldberg where he
looks at the terminology like systemic
racism racist racist white supremacy
white supremacist it's kind of like
hovering in the 1990s 2000s 2013 boom i
mean just goes straight vertical on the
graph
because the the media basically adopted
the terminology from critical race
theory and then just repeated it so many
times in their narratives and their
language and their concepts and their
terminology in their tweets um that it
became this kind of uh mythology this
new
uh mythology for uh the kind of center
left or or or liberal left in our
country
and i think that they mainstreamed or
mainlined these ideas from academia into
mainstream politics and
and now i think it's just absolutely
ridiculous what they're doing i mean
the media promoted this ideology
and now that it turns out to be
unpopular now that there's a revolt in
public schools a revolt in state
legislatures now they're retreating from
their own language and saying no no no
this is just accurate history no no no
this is just equity this is just
inclusion
it's none of those other things
that the media had been promoting for
years prior uh so
um i i have i have i am a man of little
faith and uh and i will say uh
you know even even me personally i mean
there was about two months where i was
just getting relentlessly into tact in
the media the washington post published
ten stories calling me out by name and
trashing me uh the the new york times
published multiple full pieces profiling
me uh in a very uh negative light the
atlantic msnbc's joy reid every night
for a while was putting my tweets on
screen and trying to yell at me about
them i mean
they are really dedicated to the
narrative they're trying any tactic
they're they're trying any tactic to
discredit the opposition to gaslight the
public to obscure the true nature of
their ideology that they've created but
i think that uh the american public is
too smart they see what's happening in
their local schools they see the
documents that uh that are being
released to the in in the media by me
and others
and they know that this is bad even if
they don't understand the kind of
nuances of the theory they know
instinctually they know intuitively uh
that this ideology spells trouble for
everyone it spells trouble for our
country
and i think that they are
you know in one one good thing you know
kind of referencing your your tweet
thread about loss and trust of the media
in some ways this is good i mean the
media deserves to be trusted less and it
creates the opportunity for programs
like yours for programs that are
independent to actually fill that gap
and build real trust with the audience
uh not just getting fire hosed by the
new york times uh with their you know
endless uh stream of of of gaslighting
and delusion
do you know what christopher you were
talking about how you were getting
trashed by the atlantic by msnbc by the
washington post by new york times i'm
like we could get some of that actually
yeah i'll tell you i'm pulling up my
tweets on msnbc every night come on guys
dude i'll tell you what you know i had
i've never had faster audience growth
when i was put under no really i mean
like you know and obviously like it's it
sucks it sucks to get attacked it sucks
to get you know everyone posting your
picture and yelling at you and in the
media
but i'll tell you that
the the benefit of this is that they
elevate you into a position uh where
then you become the person that is that
is that people rally to
and i think that i've for every person
that was you know that uh that they
persuaded to oppose me i gained at least
10 people that that rallied to the cause
that said actually no
this is right i'm gonna oppose uh what
the what the kind of corporate legacy
media is doing so yeah i would recommend
it um don't do anything too bad uh but
certainly if you can get some some hit
pieces uh
ultimately they say you know i don't
think this is true i think there's a
there's a there's a this is ninety-five
percent true all press is good press uh
not all press is good press but most
press is good press i think that's
that's absolutely right i think prince
andrew would disagree with that but uh
but it's a good point you make about it
because if
if you think about it from a normal
point person's point of view if you're
being attacked
by
disgusting people that no one trusts
that probably says something about you
right and i think that's kind of the
position we've got into and look
given what you're describing i think
it's really important the work that
you're doing and congratulations on on
getting the spotlight onto this issue
because as you say for us certainly here
in the uk we see it when we see protests
on our street
you know
blm protesters saying to police officers
don't shoot these police officers are
unarmed in the uk there was one person
in the whole year
or two people i think who were unarmed
who were shot and killed by the police
one of them was a terrorist who just
stabbed several people right we don't
have that problem but the ideology is
being imported and as you say america is
very good at exporting things good and
bad so all power to you keep up the
great work and as always christopher
we've got one more question for you
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be oh that's
a good question you know i think
well i guess this is maybe maybe
emerges from my own interests but i i
think it's important
i think
the kind of
intellectual counterculture and i think
i'm part of it i think you're part of it
we do a very good job at at uh kind of
rebutting or refuting the arguments of
the woke um we keep it in we do a very
good job at kind of exposing it there's
all these great publications uh but i
think we need to spend more time talking
about well what do we do about it um
because it's one thing to uh kind of you
know destroy our opponents with facts
and logic you know like that like that
kind of like meme that's great like you
should do that but
if they're in charge of all the
institutions that hold political power
and they're in charge of
billions of dollars of taxpayer
budget money uh you know our facts and
logic
don't mean much because they control
money and power so i think we should get
our hands dirtier a little bit we should
start talking about well what can we do
about it what are public policies that
we could adopt what are strategies that
we could adopt how can we actually move
the fight from the realm of the
intellect into the realm of politics and
that's something that i think i've
started to do and uh and i've seen
something very interesting you have
people now kind of
in a way schisming in a way kind of
separating where there's a certain
member of the kind of intellectual
counterculture the idw whatever you want
to call it there's a certain contingent
that says yes get rid of this in schools
and a certain contingent that says oh
well we can't do anything about this
that would be you know we can't exercise
political power we'd have to work with
the mean
mean bad you know republicans and we
can't be caught doing that we still
ultimately want the you know the
approval of the of the new york times
there is this weird division and i think
i'd like to clarify those lines i'd like
to persuade as many people as possible
to join
me in taking into the realm of action
but either way wherever you fall
wherever you kind of shake out
we should all be expected
uh to propose solutions and to propose
concrete actions uh because i think
ultimately we've done the refutation
work we've done the intellectual work uh
and we can't just keep repeating it we
need to actually move to the next phase
it's interesting you say that because in
the uk as we talked about earlier
neither francis or i are conservative uh
or right leaning really but we had an
election at the end of 2019 in which as
a country overwhelmingly we elected a
conservative government which showed
plenty of lag on the anti-work stuff and
all of that and we've ended up exactly
where we started where all of this stuff
is accepted all of this stuff is going
ahead and i think you're absolutely
right
and i i take your uh criticism
gratefully uh in that i think a lot more
of us need to start thinking about how
to have an impact on this stuff you know
the free speech union here in the uk is
doing some good work and organizations
like counterweight as well
that is something that really more
people need to get stuck into because i
think if you look at the institutional
capture of many of these places you can
get a politician into power but if if
they are still beholden to what the new
york times or the guardian says about
them you're not going to get very far
that's right and i think that you know
from my experience there's some great
folks in in your area yeah counterweight
the free speech union uh eric kaufman at
uh
at birkbeck college um you also have you
know uh uh i i'm gonna butcher her name
kemi badanok yeah yeah
unbelievable um i mean i think she's
just a absolute fire starter i love the
clips that make their way over here so
we have potential and i think also you
know maybe we can end on a note of unity
we need to revive the anglo-american
alliance we need to get all of our
people uh that we share the same values
to exchange ideas to exchange best
practices to exchange policies because
we certainly have a lot to learn from
one another and i'm grateful for the
chance to to speak with both of you
christopher thank you so much for coming
on the show if people want to find you
online or support your work where is the
best place to do that yeah follow me on
twitter at
realchrisruforufo or my website which is
christopher.com that's christopher r
ufo.com i have an amazing community of
uh small patrons and supporters uh
certainly be grateful to uh to add you
if you're listening fantastic
christopher thanks very much and of
course the idea of reigniting the
american
anglo-american alliance is great as soon
as you guys start paying taxes again now
thanks for coming on and guys thank you
for watching uh we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode like
this one or raw show all of them go out
7pm uk time uh uh or 2pm eastern time
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below